this is evergreen uh this one is very
different from last week's episode you
know with the pajama war because that
one was kind of like a I don't say like
a throwaway episode you know it was just
you know here's some fun stuff whatever
but this one was like just this
onslaught of like again like a ton of
information and like kind of no
information at the same time but mostly
a lot of information um it's uh it's
really crazy so pretty much there's I
think of wizard he can do magic and
stuff so I mean that evergreen uh and it
looks like this took place again
probably years and years ago I mean cuz
there's dinosaurs and stuff like that
and evergreen was this wizard who took
this dinosaur stole the egg it makes me
wonder where that dinosaur comes Rose
his name is Gunther well at least now we
know the original name is Gunther and
not goofy no and is pretty much a bobby
from king of the hill both the voice and
the character really it's just not a
very dinosaur but but again for you know
just being hatched a van a gate he's
able to talk to you go dinosaur you go
well remember evergreen did say he
messed with his brain yeah so I think
that's why he's able to talk probably
but still you might be the first is
would never talk so you know it was good
man dinosaurs yeah hello that is true or
Land Before Time oh yeah those are both
good very different book good I guess
the dinosaurs again actually the show
it's surprisingly much darker oh yeah
show than you would think like you're
super satirical - I'm just like lots of
cows like um it's fun to watch it again
I'm like how do they miss all advance
like there's that you lock away cuz they
think a lot of commentary and pet show
that's like all I really remember from
it was just a whole not the mama
I don't like rewatching it I'm like wow
this is ten times more adult than I
imagined yeah yeah I gotta watch it yeah
because episodes are coming my my room
like I remember they're actually being
really smart uh so I don't see it again
but we're in sight what a shot I did
invent your type you are
come on um so uh and you see these other
I guess like I'm assuming there were
wizards and there on this mountain that
serve it's like divided up and do about
four parts I think the elements that
they is that candies and element and
candies and elements fire ice slime and
candy those are the four elements
fascinating
so yeah and some of them are very
obviously voices that are supposed to
sound like voices that we've seen before
you keep David it was like the fire king
you know okay is the fire king you have
that giant fire monster who he takes out
I noticed by via it looks like tree
trunks and let's see obviously you got
Princess Bubblegum with the whole candy
thing
let's see everyone slime one princess uh
that's right princess it's been so long
you know that whole week as I say you
make it seem like it's been like forever
I know I know it's just a week yeah but
um so yet this set up and I guess
there's kind of a lesson to be learned
because you know evergreen does not
treat good turn with a lot of respect
and when he puts it I just thought that
he assumes everybody's wish when they
put the helmet on or the yeah the crown
out is going to be to get rid of the
comment yeah wait you know what comic
says because people want to live so that
be you know the wish you would want but
good to puts it on and he just see you
know and he just keeps going and going
until he turns it to the Ice King and
you don't see what happens to the comet
we're assuming it hits the planet but
then at the end we see another comment
possibly heading for the plant as well
but it looked different thought the only
look green that won't look blue only a
nice comet or something but I'm not sure
um but yeah but on top of that it's all
a dream it's all a dream of the Ice King
so it's still very likely that happened
that would be quite a wouldn't it be
like so
ballsy just to like have a totally
different backstory if you're but what
about that of us of ostracize King's
dream
like there's nothing to do with anyway
oh but we're presuming that that you
know this is what happened and all the
little penguins are terrified and yeah I
mean just like again just this big dump
of info and exposition but it's also I
liked the relationship between Evergreen
and then going to there I liked him kind
of being abused and not very smart but
he wants to learn and then I'm realizing
he never taught in magic and stuff so I
got like that you know if he should have
been nice and even though this is like
the one episode where we see the
dinosaur you feel like you know him yeah
I could get what he's about and
everything so uh yeah I thought was cool
and I'm curious where this comet thing
is going guys like I say it seems like
it's in you know the present-day there
so you know pretty good thoughts on it
see I don't I was never a huge fan of
king of the hill so when I hear it I
think of the AH blogs yeah cuz I was
saying like who is that voice I know
that voice you're like all the oblongs I
don't know what that is you're uh Oh
Bobby okay
oblong has lasted like one season no it
was never a huge yeah um but one thing
that I did like that they had that I
don't think you caught was when they
first show the comic coming towards it's
got these two extra like trails yeah who
is green with kind of almost like like
tree trunks I'll turn them it's been a
whole week okay and China remember who's
green that has this stuff out of glitch
ah
if you look at the comic coming there's
these two extra little trails like a
sauna this is interesting okay which I
thought was pretty cool
I love the evolutionary stuff they're
obviously hinting him like seeing that
giant tree trunks monster and just
knowing what that's gonna become is
hugely funny um I do like that we learn
a bit more about the past like we
learned before about Simon and where
Simon came from but he found the crown
now we actually know where the crown
came from
so it's kind of like instead of like
some shows you learn everything all at
once what I love about Adventure Time is
it's a slow progress of like slowly
turning the pages like you're actually
reading a book where as you're reading
it you're learning a bit more and more
and everything's just kind of unfolding
before you and yeah it's been six years
I think this is season six yeah we're
just learning where the crown comes from
is really cool I thought it's
interesting it reminds me a little bit
of Thor where they serve combined like
science of Technology and magic as you
see inside the crown there's all these
little gears and circuits and stuff like
that so I like that I didn't know they
were gonna eat justice Oh Oh magic it's
all magic but I like that it's kind of
this scientific route as well and it
would also kind of show why wait a
minute
because Ice King is that scientist Simon
yeah so maybe like see now trust me no I
mention the gears turning in his head so
I try thinking like maybe that's like an
offspring or maybe he lost the crown and
found it again or something it's like
not not like really intrigued you know
and what I like about this show it feels
like any other show I'd be like you know
it's doing but it's like I'm like no I
want to know how this is gonna tie
together yeah because it's like wait a
minute Simon found it cuz I was gonna
say that would explain why Simon would
find Kevin fascination with the two
because it's not just you know this
magical thing that's also all the
technology and scientific and stuff but
yeah I just realized that I'm like wait
how does it get off and then then onto
Simon if they're not the same person but
kind of are the same for us it's like
damn it stupid show could we not trying
I mean again that's really good
Adventure Time it's that whole you'll
learn eventually hmm like sooner or
later down the line but by the time you
get to that point you've forgotten kind
of about like connecting to the
connecting the dots yeah it's like by
this point in time you're like oh yeah
Simon already find the crowd no big deal
so then this episode comes out you're
like oh god that's right yeah so then
this connects so then like years down
the road we're gonna see one where Simon
finally finds it this area but it goes
to this you know so for me it's kind of
that nice thing it's like okay cool I
liked the episode Baba then you forget
about it then it comes back it's like
whoa well I'm trying to remember to like
the whole kind of apocalypse I happen
where Simon finds Marceline and stuff
like that I'm trying to remember did
Simon cause that or do we not know it
what kind of thing yeah um basically
because I mare there's something about
the more you put it on the more stuff
would get destroyed but I also remember
but he was still Simon in the apocalypse
well basically what it was and we've
only learned bits and pieces it's called
mushroom war obviously nuclear bomb yeah
so the comment that they're showing in
this one is from years and years and
years yeah because that's like before
that
yeah like thousand that Simon you tell
me put on the crown you lose more of his
mind that's all that was okay I thought
didn't stuff go like even worse when he
put the crown on or something no okay
you started going more bunkers and okay
it's tough um yeah cuz again it's you
know it could be interesting maybe
they're hinting at um
which at first I didn't sometimes I
don't like in stories but that's
actually kind of interesting with if
they do it right is history of repeating
itself because obviously you have this
comic coming down gonna hit the planet
you know but that was thousand thousand
years ago then you have the apocalypse
happens with the mushroom war and stuff
like that you know that was a long time
ago too whoa okay your farts are weirdly
alarming but and then you have this this
other comet coming you know and there is
a sense of like maybe there is just sort
of this natural destruction that keeps
happening to the world like over and
over and over like sort of a history
repeats itself thing and that's why it
would be interesting if you have like
yeah this evergreen guy you know passes
it on to Gunther becomes you know sort
of this Ice King ish character and yet
this other guy so it becomes this you
know becomes the Ice King and so friend
maybe it's just this constant repetitive
cycle of anything that creates a lot
more doom because you see the comic
coming again it's like oh well and
there's the Ice King you know how well
turned out last time so we got the crown
on and there's a comic coming so it just
really makes things you know feeling
- it's gonna go down huh so could be you
know you've already seen a lot what are
you talking about I don't know so he
could watch a lot in a week
okay he can watch like a whole season
I'm sure um so I've been wearing a watch
look hella can wears a watch anymore
hello it's right here ah kids nowadays
yeah I'm gonna look at my phone for my
time yeah ha joke's on you I have
another one damn it I'm not doing the
whole walkaway thing and that was so
last week yeah as true very last week we
should come up with a new gimmick though
whatsoever there can't get that the red
pepper